hallo ich bin der Horst in dem Jahr wo
du männlicher Österreicher Staatsbürger
18 Jahre alt wirst wirst du zu einer
zweitägigen stellungsuntersuchung
eingeladen in Ort gesunduntersuchung
wirst du komplett medizinisch und
psychologisch durchgecheckt einer dieser
stellungsstraßen ist nur in Linz in der
Garnisonstraße
[Musik]
du bist mindestens 17 Jahre
österreichische Staatsbürgerin und wirst
Soldatin beim österreichischen
Bundesheer werden ich bin die Lisa und
ihr habt die drei tägige Eignungsprüfung
mit psychologischen Test Überprüfung der
Deutschkenntnisse körperlichen
Fitnesstest und Gesundheitscheck zur
hinter mir wie das ganze genau ausschaut
schauen wir uns heute gemeinsam beim
Heeres Personalamt in Wels
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es wäre voll Fahrt wenn ihr euch das nur
sagt und deshalb mache ich jetzt gerne
mit
die wichtigste Frage am Anfang lange
Haar dürfen natürlich lang bleiben
[Musik]
jetzt fragst warum immer das ganze
eigentlich anhört dann auf jeden Fall
bei sportliche Herausforderung gerne
annehmen und so die Voraussetzungen für
die militärische Einsatzbereitschaft
gewährleiste dadurch kann die
Verantwortung für Österreich im Inland
und im Ausland übernehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ohne Fleisch kein Preis 1000 Euro im
Monat während der Ausbildungszeit macht
sich gut auf dazu gibt es nur kostenlose
Verpflegung Unterkunft und Freifahrt mit
die Öffis
[Musik]
und geht einen eigenen Weg beim
österreichischen Bundesheer
[Musik]